all right
all right all right
and we should be live
hello everyone we'll wait a minute here
as everyone gets in
and uh get started will how you doing
man
chilling um it's been a crazy week in
bitcoin but hanging in there spend a lot
of
time staring at charts this week a
little more than usual but uh doing well
how about yourself man
i've got no complaints at all normally
we've got a pretty good setup
but uh i am traveling i'm in new york
city
so we're going to do it this way and i
stream it live hopefully people like
that
let's just jump right into what happened
so obviously you have spent pretty much
the entire week looking at the on-chain
metrics and it feels like there's some
high-level takeaways maybe let's just
start there like what at a high level
happened this week when bitcoin's price
crashed
yeah so like if we just want to get you
know the gist of
the kind of tldr of what happened um you
know i think the major points are
before the you know before we had this
dump we started to see
exchange flows flip kind of bearish um
you know throughout the entire bull
market we've seen coins continually uh
you know moving off exchanges
that's been a big narrative that has
kind of been driving this cycle
but in the days before the dump
especially the day before the dump
we saw coins move on to exchanges at
like
unprecedented levels for this bull
market
um in fact like the day before the dump
we had the all-time high of coins moving
on to binance
ever like in the history of of glass
node's
data recording the exchange flows so um
there was like
a swath of coins that kind of moved on
to exchanges
presumably to sell right um i think
you know a lot of times we assume that
that coins moving on to exchanges is
only selling
um it can also be things like you know
people posting collateral
um or people you know on binance
depositing coins to use derivatives on
finance but
um a fair portion of that it's safe to
say is being sold
so we saw you know those those flows
kind of switch around
in the days before especially the the
day before wednesday on tuesday
um we started to see those coins come on
exchanges another key takeaway is that
coins that were sold were
younger which which is a good thing
because when you see
you know at cycle tops it's usually the
the
long-term holders that are kind of uh
dumping over
at the top and selling it to strength as
retail kind of comes in but what we saw
were
um young coins specifically whales so it
seemed like
perhaps funds that had gotten in and
caught the like 10 to 20 k
band um the coins that were sold were
and when you look at the age of them
that that kind of lines up with where
that where that kind of
10 to 20k band was and then there were a
fair amount that
were sold you know that had been bought
recently
probably you know in around that 55k to
60
000 range but uh there were a fair
amount that
that were sold at a loss which we can
get into um
the the big sudden price drop that we
saw especially that last
big wick down to about you know whatever
was 30k
got up to the high 20s on some exchanges
that was really driven by the
by the liquidations which we'll get into
as well
but but when you see that that big drop
that big sudden drop a lot of times what
that is is it's this cascade of
liquidations which is what happened
wednesday
um a lot of leverage has been wiped out
now um we'll get into that as well but
futures interest futures open interest
is way down from where it was at the
beginning of the week
um which is a good thing um in terms of
the leverage doesn't have the the
leverage traders don't have as much
impact on the price as spot does um
which is
which is generally good to see i'm sure
the leverage will come back
but uh for now it's it's been wiped out
um like one way to look at it is
the funding rates um but
the funding rates have been negative
since wednesday so it's showing
the traders are not looking to go long
right now and funding is pretty much
dead um
and then the coins that the coins that
are being sold now you know
i think it's just gonna take a while for
for the coins to kind of uh sift into
new hands that are that are not gonna
sell
that process of kind of reaccumulation
if you will is
is going to take a little bit of time
for sure yeah
what that really kind of um in your
analysis that
uh to me was super interesting was this
idea of the energy value
and i know that this is part of the
whole idea of like the bull market still
being intact but maybe explain a little
bit
uh about this energy value um and
what exactly that is how it works and
why it's important
yeah so this was a um a model
created by uh charles edwards who he's
famous for creating like the hash
ribbons and then he's also created this
energy value based on
uh you know the hashing going into
bitcoin
um to be honest i don't know the exact
calculation that goes into
um creating it but um it's based off of
the energy
input that's going into bitcoin which is
correlated with with the hash power
going up
so it was interesting we we touched this
energy
um value that that charles edwards has
created
for the first time ever in a bull market
um and so he posted something and he
said
this is the you know the the uh
generational opportunity to buy
bitcoin the best big opportunity to buy
in a bull market because we touched this
energy price
that um i think if he was saying
if we had broken that then he would have
kind of flipped a little more uh
bearish but the fact that we bounced off
of that he in his opinion shows that
we're still in this bull market
got it and then when you talk about the
um kind of age of coins and the funding
rates i think that we've covered that in
past videos so i don't want to spend a
ton of time on that
sure but i do think that the
liquidations
um i think it was over 300 million
dollars in liquidations
uh happened within like 10 minutes and
that really drove
that kind of deep price um you know kind
of
drop talk a little bit about that is
that a big number
or have we seen that before
yeah so you know what led to that was we
saw 59
and 313 coins moved on to exchanges
within four days and then so that spot
selling
obviously starts to push the price down
um and then traders all have
um stop losses set so if i'm if i'm
taking an entry into bitcoin and i'm a
trader
at whatever i'm just making up a number
here fifty thousand
i set my stop loss at forty eight
thousand so that's basically
the risk mechanism where um if bitcoin
falls below that especially if i'm using
leverage
um i wanna have a tight stop loss so
that
um if the trade goes against where i
think it's going to go
that i don't i don't uh lose a lot of a
lot of my position
um so what happens is
when when spot starts pushing the price
down um
especially below a kind of a key
liquidation price that's recognized by
the
by the broader market um you start to
get this cascade effect
where um a lot a lot of traders
stop losses or liquidation prices are
hit and then
they have to sell their their four
sellers and then
that that cascades the price even
further down
so what we saw was you know we had that
spot selling that that was driving the
price down
but as we were going down um the
leveraged traders kept trying to step in
and
and long every single time they thought
it was the bottom the whole way down
so you know obviously in in previous
videos i've been talking about how
um i've been you know bullish and uh
just kind of describing this bullish
setup which um
you know i still think holds true in the
mid to longer term
um obviously i kind of miscalculated the
short term price action a little bit um
but you know i think it did become
obvious though that we were going to
keep going down
once this began um because what happened
was
every time the price dropped down
leveraged traders stepped in
and tried to go you know whatever trying
to go 20x
the bottom um and and they thought they
were gonna ride the thing the way the
way up was they
they're like okay this is the absolute
bottom i'm gonna go
super long leverage here it kept
happening and so
i was like we're gonna need some kind of
big flush and then
wednesday morning we got that we got you
know
over 300 it was 303 million dollars of
long liquidations within a 10 minute
period and the market can't
um sustain their that kind of selling
especially when it's
uh very fragile like it was on wednesday
so
um that that was what caused that that
big nasty wick
that we saw down to 30k or whatever was
28k on some exchanges
got it and then in the letter that you
wrote yesterday you talked a lot about
like the first
real capitulations uh for the first time
since march 2020
uh and you even talked about kind of
sopra and dipping below one maybe talk a
little bit about those on-chain metrics
and kind of why you think that was
uh kind of true capitulation that we saw
earlier this week
yeah so glass node has this metric
called nupl
which is called a net unrealized profit
loss
and so the way you kind of think of this
is like when we get to the top of the
bull market
um people people stop taking profits
because people think that things go into
the moon and they're like all right i'm
not gonna sell
because this thing it's done a thousand
you know a thousand percent it's gonna
do another thousand percent and people
get
very complacent and stop taking profits
and so
this metric um nupl it kind of
um it has these different zones where it
kind of
identifies the the market behavior based
off of um
whether people are taking profits or not
and so you have these
different zones there's capitulation
hope and fear
optimism anxiety belief denial and
euphoria and greed
and so we got up near um in
there there's two there's a longer term
uh nupl and then the shorter term
mupl and the longer term one we actually
got near
kind of that uh euphoria agreed and
call it you know mid uh february when we
were really on a tear
when we went from like 30k to 40k in
like a week or whatever was 10 days
um but now on the on the shorter term
time frame
we're in kind of this deeper
capitulation
that we that we kind of dove into on
wednesday which
meant that you know people are kind of
panicking and then they're starting to
um sell a lot more than they have at any
more any
other time in the in the bull market and
soper is
so pretty similar in the sense that
soper looks at you know the uh
behavior of buyers and sellers on any
given day
and it determines okay um what is
what is the uh average the aggregate
profit
of the coins on those days and so for
the first time
um like i've described sober in some of
the previous letters on very short time
frames
um but soper just running a like a
broader seven day moving average which
is
taking a little bit more of a zoomed out
view for the broader
bull market we um actually dip below
that that sober level
on on wednesday which was the first time
we had dipped below sober
on on a broader seven seven-day moving
average um
since september i think you remember
when we had that
um that fairly big crash was like 20 25
um towards i think it was like mid
mid-september or late september
um when we were start kind of you know
getting the bull run kicked off there
but
it was the first time we uh had a solid
breakthrough
that that loss threshold um
since then so yeah the market the
market's definitely underwater
um when you also look at um the realized
cap that's another way to kind of
look at this so that we've talked about
this before the the realized cap is uh
the market capitalization
based off of um i'm sorry it's the
capitalization based off of
when the coins move last so when
when coins let's say you know someone
bought it a hundred thousand
and they never move the coins well yeah
those hundred thousand coins are worth
whatever three point uh if they bought
them at a dollar now there were three
point eight billion dollars right but
the only hundred thousand dollars would
be added to realize cap
because that was when the coins were
moved last um
and so we actually saw realized cap go
down
um throughout the dip which means the
following so
if we had seen it go up that would mean
that the coins that we're selling were
last moved at lower prices
but since we saw realized capco go down
it means that the coins that were being
sold had last moved at higher prices so
for example
if a coin was um you know last moved at
uh 64k and now the coin
sold at 40 000. well all of a sudden
um twenty four thousand dollars was
removed from realize cap because the
coin was
last moved um at 64k
and then now it just moved at 40k so
i think um that that shows that
the market was realizing losses um
pretty heavily on on wednesday
and it appears to be people that had
gotten in and
um you know in the last week to month we
saw a lot of selling coming from those
those uh that cohort of coins probably
people that had
you know just kind of speculatively got
in um in the last month or so
yeah and it feels like as we saw those
young coins sell off
we also saw some some movement in wales
as well
one of the things that you highlighted
is the otc desk outflows
and why that spiked maybe talk a little
bit about that
yeah so you know for for high net worth
individuals
and institutions they're um not going
through exchanges
um a lot of them are going through otc
desks
um and and so you know when you see
spikes in that that kind of
to me at least illustrates that those uh
those high net worth individuals and
institutions are buying and on wednesday
we saw this huge spike
in otc outflows which was a good sign
you saw those institutions come in and
buying the dip
you know on a similar note i think this
is this is interesting to note um
when we were kind of bouncing off the
bottom off that 30k bottom
um it seemed like a lot of the buying
was coming from
the us because coinbase
that that's the that's the exchange that
the us mainly goes through and then
finance is mainly asia
biff and x okay x those are more asian
asian-based exchanges um but throughout
well you know when we bounced up
coinbase was trading at like a three
thousand dollar premium to the other
exchanges which means that um
whoever was on coinbase was absolutely
smashing the green button
um and and i think that that jokes that
goes to show that there's a lot of
u.s demand around those levels
and so when you start to look at stable
coin flows i think that's another thing
that you highlighted in just the
importance of kind of how much capital
is flowing in the system
either buying or ready to buy
yeah so you know following the dip we
saw a fair amount of tether
moved on to exchanges and the first hour
after dip we saw over 500 million
dollars of tether moved on to exchanges
and you know if you just look and zoom
out at kind of the net flow day-to-day
um you know after after the dip we've
seen this
big kind of if you will dense cluster of
inflows
of daily inflows the biggest spike i
think was
around when elon musk bought it like the
beginning of february the biggest single
day spike
but we're seeing continued inflows day
after day um
since since that dip so i think that
that's interesting you know
when you look at um stable coins a lot
of times that can help you kind of get a
gauge of
yeah maybe that capital isn't buying
right now but yeah it's sitting on the
exchanges and
it's kind of waiting to be deployed so i
think stable coin flows are something
you have to look at this cycle that
run around in you know in 2017 obviously
because they didn't exist back then
so it's kind of a a non-bitcoin
blockchain metric that that i think is
important to take a look at
got it and then one of the things that's
the most fascinating to me
is this whole idea that the bull
market's still intact but there's a lot
of data that suggests
uh actually things were starting to heat
up and and it felt like okay we may be
getting overheated now they're actually
cooling off so things like reserve risk
explain what that is and kind of why
that's important
yeah so reserve risk is another one of
those kind of a
broader cycle metrics that that you look
at to kind of identify
the the bear zones where the market's
kind of oversold
and then as well these um these
overheated zones so
reserve risk is is the calculation for
this price divided by huddlebank so
the way you could just think of this is
that when price is low
and confidence is high that's when
that's when reserve risk is low
but when price is high and confidence
from from holders
is low that's when reserve risk goes up
and so then at the end of the bull
market price is high
and confidence is very low price is very
high
confidence is very low so you get these
overheated zones um
usually over like 0.02
um in in terms of that and the reserve
risk ratio but what we're seeing now is
you know we got up to kind of
call it halfway um of where we've gotten
in
in terms of overheatedness compared to
the previous cycles and then now we're
just in this cooling off period
which shows that price is going down but
but
confidence from from the longer term
holders isn't moving or is actually
going up
so i think this is this is a good way to
kind of show that
yeah the the bull market is you know
we're cooling off here but it's not over
because we didn't reach that overheated
euphoric zone
and then what about mv rv
yeah so mvrv is it's a very simple ratio
of the market capitalization
to the realized cap and so
it's another it's another metric where
you know you can identify these
these overheated zones um and then
there's another
kind of a um a subset off of this um
mvrv z score which basically adjusts it
for volatility and gives these very
distinct
overheated zones neither of those have
we hit
any kind of overheated mark and
what i'm looking at and you know we're
cooling off a lot
on both of those what that shows is you
know the market cap is going down
um and the realized cap has gone up i
mean i'm trending looking this over
a two to three month period since call
it you know the end of
end of january uh beginning of february
and
and this has been trending down since
then so um
you know that that's showing that we're
just kind of in this cool off period and
once again we haven't hit
um at least a historical overheated zone
um so yeah i think that's uh
that's just another metric you know
there's there's like three or four of
these and
i think the key takeaway here is like we
haven't hit overheated zones on any of
these yet we're cooling off
so if unless bitcoin does something that
it's never done before
the bull market isn't over based off of
bitcoin's historical action
got it and then maybe the last thing is
just talk about the volume distribution
and then we'll let everyone go
but i think the volume distribution is
really interesting um kind of comparing
where we are today versus historical
bull markets yeah so
you know in in each bull market you see
around like two to three x the previous
all-time high this big
base of capital kind of flowing this
that we see this big consolidation
um and we started to see that you know
call it around
uh let me say like mid 40s to call it
58k especially between 54 000 to 58k you
saw a lot of coins moving hands
um over 25 of supply is moved above the
40k
threshold and and what you see at bull
market tops is you don't see a lot of
distribution
so you know um if you look in the
newsletter
you see i saw some comments that that it
looked the same i mean i suppose it
looks the same in the in the kind of the
the pattern of it but the actual density
the the percentage of supply moved at
each of those levels is
is not even comparable because
especially
in that you know in that 54 to 60 000
range we have a lot of distribution
there meaning
you know a lot of a lot of coins a lot
of people bought in at those levels a
lot of
new capitals flown in between that 40 to
60k band
so you know at the top a lot of coins
don't change hands
whereas now we're kind of seeing the
opposite in the zone that we're in
so the signature of that in terms of the
urpd if this if that was the top
um it would be kind of unprecedented as
well
um and and also you know two
two other things you know the stock to
flow deflection i think this is very
interesting
um you know a lot of people are calling
the stock flow model dead
but it's had a bigger deflection than it
has before um this is like the third
largest deflection it's had to the
downside
uh so that you know that's that's one
interesting thing to keep in mind i
think
i i'm a pro a general proponent of the
stock to flow i don't
follow it in terms of like the the exact
price but in the general sense i think
there is a correlation there between
um you know the supply and price
so i think that'll be interesting to
take a look at and then also willie wu's
um nvt price which um i think it's only
been broken
um for you know significant amount of
time not just like one daily close
one or two other times i think once in
2017 and once in 2013
and we're very um undervalued relative
to that ratio
which is just like a very basic ratio of
uh like the network the market cap
uh to the to the uh like the unchained
transactional volume
um and so you can kind of think of that
as like we're undervalued compared to
the
underlying um investor activity that's
going on in the blockchain
so i think that's another thing i'm
going to be keeping an eye on because
that model um that model has has uh
served as a good pricing mechanism for
bitcoin throughout
its history so i think you know if if
if bitcoin goes into a bear market from
here um it would be
pretty um i think a lot of these models
that we're all using
would kind of be invalidated which in my
opinion
um isn't gonna happen because they've
worked for
all of bitcoin's history so um it's
something we're definitely going to have
to keep an eye on over the next couple
weeks
but based off of the data and the
historical you know
action of these different indicators i
remain bullish and i think
we are still in that in that bull market
it's just going to take some time at
this point
for the coins that were kind of panic
sold over the last
week or so to kind of uh find their way
into uh strong hands
but yeah i would say you know kind of
base case
expect consolidation over the next
couple weeks or so i mean this is going
to take some time now
um i think this is this is
we're still in consolidation but it's
just gonna it's putting a damper on how
long
we may break out of the consolidation it
may be a while for
um for that process to happen but i i
yeah it's still really bullish
awesome this is a fantastic work for
those that are
listening live uh or watching um
afterwards i'm putting in the chat right
now will's new
email he's doing a fantastic job so
please go subscribe to that
and then every friday he's gonna be
writing a guest post uh for the pomp
letter so make sure you're
subscribed there and then uh we're gonna
do these every saturday sometimes
they'll be live sometimes they won't
but hopefully you guys are all learning
from this so will thank you so much for
uh
for taking the time to do this you're
doing a great job and hopefully people
are enjoying it
thanks a lot pump you know have a good
weekend man and uh i'm looking forward
to getting some bitcoin pizza you got to
get that out to raleigh
i'm working on it i'm